wendung gemüse oder fleisch einkochen
möchtest dann ist botulismus eine sache
mit der du dich auf jeden fall
auseinandersetzen sollte ist
beziehungsweise eigentlich muss es ist
mir wirklich ein ganz großes anliegen
darüber zu sprechen denn in deutschland
ist das noch weitestgehend unbekannt
in anderen ländern ist es total normal
dass man darauf achtet dass man eben
diese botulismus bakterien abtötet beim
einkochen und bei sauren lebensmitteln
wie fleisch und gemüse darauf achte dass
meiner techniken verwendet die eben
diesen bakterien auch zu leibe rücken
können in deutschland ist es aber
irgendwie überhaupt kein thema ich weiß
gar nicht woran das liegt warum wir da
so rückständig sind es sind relativ neue
studien die eben zeigen wie gefährlich
botulismus ist und wie und wo sich
botulismus bakterien in ein gekochtem
ausbreiten können aber das ist etwas wo
wir jetzt einen schlussstrich ziehen und
wo ich auf jeden fall auf diesem kanal
darüber sprechen möchte
denn wenn du deinen liebsten etwas
auslöst dass du sehr haltbar gemacht
hast das aus dem eigenen garten kommt
würde so viel liebe rein gesteckt hast
du auch super stolz drauf bist das soll
am liebsten der ganzen welt schenken
möchte sein der familie ist auf tust
dann soll das ja bitte nicht potenziell
tödlich sein denn botulismus ist in
vielen fällen tödlich das ist selten
botulismus eine der schlimmsten
lebensmittelvergiftungen überhaupt und
die tritt selten auf aber sie kann eben
auftreten in säure abend lebensmitteln
das heißt wenn der ph wert dessen was du
ein kochst unter einem bestimmten wert
liegt dann ist das ganze anfällig für
botulismus das sind kleine bakterien
gekommen so gut wie überall vor in der
erde im wasser auf dem gemüse das ist
auch alles überhaupt kein problem
problematisch wird es erst wenn diese
bakterien
luftabschluss in säure abend
lebensmittel sich vermehren das ist ihre
umgebung in der sie sich vermehren in
der sie sich wohlfühlen und dann
schütten die einen giftstoff aus ein
toxin das potenziell tödlich ist da
reicht dann auch schon in kleiner löffel
von deinem gemüse dass du selber
eingekocht hast um botulismus zu
bekommen und die todesrate ist leider
sehr sehr hoch es sterben immer noch
jedes jahr leute in deutschland an ein
gekochtem weil sie nicht richtig
eingekocht haben das ist natürlich sehr
sehr selten also ich möchte hier absolut
keine panik verbreiten und niemanden
scheu machen einkaufen ist eine super
tolle möglichkeit deine ernte haltbar zu
machen aber damit musst du dich
auseinandersetzen wenn du selber ein
kochst und du musst wissen ab wann muss
ich denn das ganze in einem
druckindustrie top halver machen und
wann kann ich es ganz normal im
wasserbad einkochen was sich dann auch
zu hören bekomme ist die aussage ja aber
wir kochen das ganze doch ein dann sind
doch die bakterien tod ja im prinzip
stimmt dass auch diese bakterien diese
botulismus bakterien sind aber besonders
hartnäckig die sterben erst ab
temperaturen von 120 grad und eine
temperatur von 120° die schafft man in
normalen ein kochtopf rein physikalisch
einfach nicht es muss unter druck
passieren deswegen braucht man einen
druck ein kochtopf ich gar nicht gerne
mal hier ausschnitte von mainburg ein
kochtopf einblenden damit ihr seht wie
der aussieht ist und ganz schönes
wachstum die gibt es aber in allen
möglichen größen es ist natürlich
komplizierter mit so einem druck ein
kochkessel einzukochen denn da der hat
alle möglichen funktionen
sicherheitsventile die man sich wirklich
auskennen muss denn darin herrscht
richtig druck und da kann wenn man da
nicht sachgerecht mit umgeht können da
auch unfälle passieren also es ist
wichtig dass wenn du so einen topf
verwendest dass du dann auch weißt wie
du mit dem umgehst und indie
top können ebenso hohe temperaturen
entstehen die dann die botulismus
bakterien und die spuren abtöten so dass
du das ganze sicher essen kannst und die
sache ist ich wusste dass ganz lange
nicht weil es in deutschland einfach
nicht zum einkochen wissen unserer
nation gehört dass man so den teil
verwenden sollte wenn man eure arme
lebensmitte ein kocht also ihr müsst
euch keine sorgen machen bei obst
enthält genug säure außer bananen liebe
nicht genug säure enthalten aber bei
obst könnt ihr ganz normal euren
normalen ein kochtopf verwenden aber bei
gemüse und bei fleisch eben nicht und
das muss sich einfach nicht und ich habe
zum beispiel ganz viele boden eingekocht
aus meinem garten und das war so
frustrierend dann zusehen okay ich kann
die jetzt einfach niemanden mehr
vorsetzen wo ich dieses wissen habe
natürlich ist es unwahrscheinlich dass
irgendwas passiert aber wenn die
möglichkeit besteht dann kann ich das
doch nicht mehr verwenden und deswegen
bin ich auch super froh dass wir vor ein
paar jahren auf diesen druck einfach
klasse umgestiegen sind weil wir uns
darüber jetzt einfach keine gedanken
mehr machen müssen ich hab das auch
ehrlich gesagt ich habe einen onlinekurs
zum haltbarmachen der eigenen ernte und
ich habe in meinem kurs diese unsicheren
anleitungen weitergegeben weil ich das
einfach nicht wusste und ich hatte so
ein schlechtes gewissen
also jetzt haben wir das natürlich alles
sicher überarbeitet der kurs öffnet auch
bald wieder
also da könnt ihr wenn ihr in meinem
newsletter eingetragen seid dann kriegt
ihr auf jeden fall bescheid wenn er
wieder öffnet falls ihr datei legen volt
freue ich mich supermarkt über aber das
hat mir echt ganz schön schlechtes
gewissen gemacht dass ich da diese
unsicheren anleitungen weitergegeben
habe eine frage die auch immer wieder
kommt ist sie wie erkenne ich denn wenn
ich jetzt schon etwas eingekocht habe ob
er jetzt botulismus bakterien drin sind
oder nicht und die sache ist bei vielen
anderen sachen die in deinem ein kochte
als schief gehen da merkt man das ja
weil sich dann der decke wird bei der
decke wenn man die weg leser verwendet
zum beispiel nur noch lose aufliegt und
kein vakuum bei einem glas herrscht aber
bei botulismus bakterien ist das eben
nicht zwangsläufig der fall ich will
jetzt nicht zu tief einsteigen aber es
gibt zwei stämme von botulismus
bakterien der eine zersetzt eiweiß der
andere nicht und gerade dieser zweite
ist ebenso problematisch weil sich da
das vakuum weiter im glas hält weil man
da auch keinen anzeichen erkennen kann
von außen ob da drin jetzt botulismus
bakterien sind oder nicht und das macht
das ganze ebenso heikel das heißt du
hast hinterher keine chance zu sagen
okay da sind jetzt bakterien drin oder
nicht also das ist echt ne ziemlich
vertrackte vertrackte angelegenheit wenn
du jetzt noch ganz viele zum beispiel
boden in der im schrank stehen hat boden
sind besonders anfällig für botulismus
übrigens dann würde ich dir empfehlen
wenn du die noch essen willst dass du
die ungefähr 15 minuten lang brodelnd
kochst bevor du die ist das sollte die
toxine aus dem essen heraus kochen die
sind nämlich hitzeempfindlich und dann
kannst du das immer noch essen aber
richtig appetitlich ist das nicht oder
wenn man weiß da kann können potenziell
tödliche gifte drin sein in meinem essen
ich habe übrigens eine checkliste
erstellt für alle von euch die mir von
ihrer ernte haltbar machen möchten sich
mehr mit dem thema haltbarmachen
auseinandersetzen möchten wir lernen
möchten neue techniken lernen möchten
auch lernen möchten wie man sicher ein
kocht da findet ihr hier ganz viele
informationen da fängt es erst mal an
mit gemüsen die man im winter anbauen
kann das natürlich auch total schön wenn
man statt aus der vorratskammer ganz
viel auch aus dem garten essen kann
wildpflanzen die man erhalten kann
und hier findet ihr zum beispiel auch
eine anleitung zum einkochen unter druck
diese checkliste könnt ihr euch gerne
herunterladen die habe ich euch einfach
hier unten unter dem video in der video
beschreibung verlinkt eine anlage die
ich immer wieder zu hören bekommen
dadurch über sozialismus spreche und
auch über botulismus schreibe
viele leute sagen ja meine oma hat immer
gleich und bohnen im wasserbad
eingekocht und bei uns ist auch nie
jemand gestorben und es ist eine aussage
die ich ein bisschen schwierig finde
weil natürlich ist es selten dass
botulismus passiert aber früher hatte
man einfach nicht das wissen dass das
ganze nicht im wasserbad eingekocht
werden sollte heutzutage haben wir das
wissen es gibt nur die reine studien die
kann ich euch gerne in die infobox
packen so dass ihr euch die auch
anschauen könnt die sagen nicht gemüse
und fleisch im wasserbad einkochen das
ist nicht sicher und es gibt leute die
daran sterben früher wusste man ja auch
oft gar nicht wenn jemand gestorben ist
woran das liegen könnte natürlich ist
das nur selten passiert aber es ist
passiert ist heutzutage immer noch und
ich finde mit diesem wissen dass wir
heutzutage haben muss man dann eben auch
mal alte techniken über bord schmeißen
und sich dem anpassen um eben die eigene
familie die eigene gesundheit zu
schützen das ist tourismus gibt war
übrigens schon im 18 jahrhundert bekannt
aber diese neuen studien die eben genau
sagen wir brauchen diese 120 grad grenze
die ech wäert analysiert haben und
getestet haben ab welchem ph-wert können
die sich denn vermehren und ab welchem
nicht so dass man eben auch sichere
rezepte entwickeln kann
die sind relativ neu und ich finde wenn
man eben diese erkenntnis jetzt hat dann
kann man eben sich auch dementsprechend
verhalten wie gesagt lasst euch nicht
abschrecken lasst euch nicht vom
einfachen abhalten besorgt euch einen
druck ein kochkessel wenn ihr gemüse
oder fleisch haltbar machen möchte
im moment sind die ziemlich ausverkauft
weil er wegen coruna eben eine riesige
nachfrage besteht
die werden vor allem in amerika
hergestellt weil es in deutschland eben
noch nicht wirklich
erkennen gibt dass man diese druck
einfach kessel verwenden sollte ich kann
euch gucken ob ich einen link finde von
einem kessel der zurzeit verfügbar ist
dann wenn ich einen finde packe stehen
in die video beschreibung ansonsten
denke ich dass in den nächsten wochen
wie der neue kessel produziert werden
sollten
also ja es ist ziemlich abgegrast der
marketing moment durch das gruner videos
und weil viele leute eben jetzt noch
mehr selber anbauen wollen mehr haltbar
machen möchten ihren eigenen kleinen
wintervorrat anlegen möchten
deswegen ist es gerade ein bisschen
schwierig an diese kessel zu kommen aber
ich gehe stark davon aus dass sich das
bald wieder ändert und wenn ich irgendwo
im kessel finde oder wenn ihr einen
classic findet dann schreibt das gerne
unten in die kommentare oder in die
schranken die video beschreibung ihr in
die kommentare
damit wir uns da gegenseitig
weiterhelfen können für die leute die
lust haben das einfach dem druck das
thema auszuprobieren wenn ihr wissen
wollt welche gemüse ihr mit welchen
techniken halver machen könnt ein kochen
ist ja nicht die einzige technik da
draußen
dann schaut euch gerne dieses video da
trieben an da unten verlinkt ich euch
meine tour durch unsere selbstversorger
vorratskammer wenn euch das interessiert
schaut euch gerne das video da unten an
ansonsten sehen wir uns nächsten samstag
wieder wie immer um 10 uhr hier auf dem
kanal vista